one of the thoughts that I kept having
sort of in my in my piece was that I'm
not an atheist welcome gentlemen both
it's a nice discussion I'm really
looking forward to what we're going to
be covering tonight because I've had you
on the show before John and very often
I've put you in conversation with maybe
a quite firm atheist someone like a
Dawkins or an Atkins or Michael ruse but
I think tonight's gonna be a little bit
different because I'm really looking
forward to hearing your story Dave we
haven't met before factored tonight was
the first time but I've watched your
stuff and I've seen some of the people
that you've increasingly been talking to
and being influenced yourself and and
it'll be fascinating to hear where
you're at now in terms of both the
cultural and religious aspects of you
well I've never had anyone give me an
intro and say we'll label him later so
I'm feeling really undue pressure right
now and I'm the only one here from SoCal
let's see what happens well whatever
those labels may be I'm really looking
forward to what what you're gonna bring
to us tonight perhaps will we'll start
with you first of all they tell us a
little bit about who you are growing up
I know that you came from a pretty
religious family so you want to tell a
little bit about that and where you
found yourself as you grew up and as
regards sort of faith and so on sure
first off I just want to say what a
pleasure it is to be here you know I'm
usually on the other side of the
interview and the reason I'm
particularly excited about tonight is
that I don't talk about this sort of
thing from a personal perspective that
often you know I've sat down with tons
of atheists you know Sam Harris and
Michael Shermer and Peter Bogosian and
that whole crew and I've talked to
plenty of people of faith like Bishop
Baron and rabbi Whoopi and plenty of
other people that come from from
different political perspectives and
personal perspectives and I always find
that I go into each interview with with
no agenda other than hearing their
thoughts
and seeing how that shakes out around my
worldview that being said I'm excited to
be here because I can sort of tell you a
little bit more about about where I come
from and sort of where I'm at so I grew
up in a conservative Jewish household in
New York we kept kosher we did Shabbat
on Friday nights while all the big
holidays but there was a strong secular
belief within that and as I was telling
you sort of backstage you know there's a
there's an interesting piece related to
Judaism that I think is a little
different than other religions in that
the ethnic tie to it at least in a
modern way is for most Jews more
important than the religious nature of
it specifically let's say beliefs
specifically because John as we were
talking about there are many many Jews
especially in Sciences and in
mathematics that aren't believers per se
but have a real cultural affinity and I
would say that that's sort of where I'm
at or at least where I've been over the
last couple years I actually am now in
the last few years and this has to do a
lot with being on tour with Jordan
Peterson for a year
Jordan and I did about a hundred and ten
stops in one calendar year in about 20
countries it was pretty amazing and when
you spend that kind of time
listening to a true innovative thinker I
mean truly the guy that I think is is
the world's most important public
philosopher and let's say you know
talking about his biblical lectures and
talking about his perspective on life
and that there has to be a bedrock of
something that is real and true outside
of us and then how he relates that
through the biblical stories it moved me
it moved me over the course of the year
that we did this together so I would say
I'm secular basically in my life but I
definitely in the last year have found
that there has to be something outside
of
the rest of this makes no sense I mean
the part very briefly the part that you
know I'm really known for is the
political part that I was lefty and and
the difference between letting on a
political conversion I had it right so
I'm usually much more comfortable
talking about my political immersion
than a religious one but but I would say
this that consistent with me talking
about sort of what's happened with the
postmodern left with the progressives
and we see this now where there's sort
of nothing that's empirically true and
any any given day you can feel anything
about any particular topic there's a
reason for that and the reason is
they've disconnected everything their
whole worldview is disconnected to
anything that came before them so that
that could be God or a religious set of
ideas or something like that so I'm
really really fascinated by that at the
moment and it's it's changing how I live
my life I just did it was Yom Kippur
which is the holiest day in Judaism I
was at a service that was actually at a
church in in Pasadena in Los Angeles
hosted by by Dennis Prager that I'm sure
many of you guys know about Dennis
Prager who many of you know so I'm sort
of I would say I'm in it the way you
guys are all in it well trying to find
some truth in the madness I'll be
interested to tease that out a little
more into course I mean one one thing I
did notice is I I've seen just watching
some of your videos that there
definitely been a progression in your
thinking on this and and probably if you
go back a few years I think you had said
along the lines have you probably
thought of yourself as an atheist but
evidently that's not quite the case
anymore well I had a bunch of atheist
high-profile atheists on the show in a
row yeah starting with Sam Harris who I
admire and he's a good friend of mine
and Michael Shermer and Peter Bogosian
and I really love the intellectual side
of that I really really do love it and
that's not at the exclusion of anything
else actually but what I found was that
I had had a series of atheists on in a
row and then people online just can't
kept saying that I was an atheist right
and and then I sort of just said it one
without it didn't it didn't mean
anything to me sort of one way or
another it was almost it just sort of
came it just sort of came out of my
mouth one day and then two years ago you
know I do this off-the-grid August thing
where I literally locked my phone in a
safe and I don't look at any news or
television I am completely offline and I
really disappear and I try to let my
brain reset and and two years ago when I
did it one of the thoughts that I kept
having sort of in my in my piece was
that I'm not an atheist and I came back
and I said in a very casual way on I
just did this live stream where I just
sort of said it very flippantly that I
just don't like the word atheist it
doesn't it doesn't fit what I believe I
do believe in something else even if I
can't completely articulate what it is I
think Jordan has gone a long way to
articulate a the type of thing that I
believed in and I got a lot of a lot of
hate for that one because you know the
atheist they don't like a converted
person either so you know you got to
watch out for that too so you know we
all have our own trappings but what I'm
most interested in is is talking to
people from all walks of life and
figuring out what the common stuff is
and what I like to frame that around is
a conversation about freedom and how do
we how do we limit government we can all
believe what we want to believe and
think what we want to think and be part
of a society that's pluralistic and
decent for all of us John let's have a
bit of an introduction to you for those
who aren't familiar with you tell us
about your own faith journey up to this
point you now obviously speak to many
people all over the world about
Christianity but but where did it all
begin for you it began for me lemme say
as well her delighted I am to be back in
Costa Mesa and I've enjoyed in the past
some marvelous shows with Justin and I'm
just fascinated by what's going to
happen in the conversation tonight but I
grew up in Northern Ireland which isn't
always the best start to discuss
religion because it was a divided
community
there was a lot of terrorism that was
connected in a very complex way to
Christianity of both versions Protestant
and Catholic but the important thing was
that my parents were very unusual for
that kind of cultural context they were
Christian convinced Christians but they
weren't sectarian and that was very
unusual my father had a small business
we lived in a small town 15,000 or so
and he tried to employ people from both
sides of the community nowhere did he do
that I once asked him I said dad it's so
risky and he was bombed for doing this
my brother nearly lost his life and he
said look he said I believe that every
person whatever they believe is of
infinite value because they're made in
the image of God going back to the
Hebrew Scriptures and therefore I will
employ across the community and that is
stuck with me and it's been very
important when you're discussing as I
often do with people that do not share
my worldview
that always comes to my mind here's a
person in front of me and it relates to
what you were saying about freedom I
would connect with freedom value that
here's something outside of my parents
that gave every human being dignity and
value that was point number one the
second thing was that they allowed me to
think now northern islands often
associative or religious bigotry extreme
fundamentalism all this kind of thing
and my parents were not highly educated
but they really gave me space so my
first encounter with Christianity was
not mind closing it was mind expanding
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist there are
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell